se puede lograr una nueva mayoría son
los primeros comentarios de manuel
mccrone después de las parlamentarias
del 19 de junio
colisionar con el gobierno y pasar a la
acción
para avanzar de manera útil corresponde
ahora a los grupos políticos decir con
toda transparencia hasta dónde están
dispuestos a llegar
al la primera ronda de contactos con los
partidos de la asamblea nacional fue
inconclusa y su propuesta de un gobierno
de unidad fue rechazada por la mayoría
de opositores aunque el partido
comunista de fabián hoss él se mostró
abierto al tema
lo que le dije el presidente de la
república fue que había iniciativas
fuertes que tomar allí en los días en
las semanas que vienen especialmente en
torno a trabajo
macro reconoció los motivos que le
hicieron perder el liderazgo
ya no puedo ignorar las fracturas y
divisiones profundas en todo el país que
se reflejan en la composición de la
nueva asamblea expresan preocupación es
el sentimiento de estar atrapados en la
vida sin perspectiva y en varios de
nuestros barrios populares así como en
nuestros pueblos giras en otras orillas
esta semana los republicanos descartaron
un pacto inicial con el partido
gobernante aunque dejaron la puerta
abierta
la línea de conducta es extremadamente
clara somos un grupo de oposición pero
quizás podamos convertirnos en esta
configuración totalmente nueva en un
grupo de oposición que sea capaz de
negociar el progreso de los franceses y
del desarrollo por eso mientras los
líderes de la izquierda y de la
ultraderecha rechazaron cualquier
acuerdo que venga de un cambio radical
en ese tono margen le pen y agrupación
nacional celebró su bancada que pasó de
8 a 89 diputados ya lenguaje y un saludo
abajo van a ver que vamos a realizar un
trabajo muy importante con gran
competencia y de manera seria un poco
distinto a lo que ustedes tienen la
costumbre de decir sobre nosotros pues
de ávila visitó inyección para evitar
bloqueos juntos de macrón tendrá que
buscar aliados en el centro y en los
conservadores